hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil 3
hello sewers map this is probably very
useful I didn't know that I needed then
also I got an achievement that said that
the Nemesis dropped something it was
something about relinquishing an item
and I don't know if there was something
that the Nemesis drops when he goes down
to one knee like a [ __ ] but I'm
guessing that you get a reward that's
what I said but ok steal my thunder why
don't you but I'm guessing that I should
be on the lookout for that if that
happens again which it will there a
giant Gator down there man that's a lot
of poop is this what sewers are really
like guys a horrifying river of boob oh
god how does this not smell worse than
that place outside there ooh I want I
want I want I want I want I want that I
want that how do I get in there I don't
even see good question
I'm actually kind of curious about what
was that oh I'm gonna go in the poop
water man
these but these stars officers really do
deal with a lot of [ __ ] ok some kind of
electrical lock is that what this says
we've been receiving reports of
unauthorized personnel in the control
areas of the facility in response we're
replacing the aging mechanical ox and
implementing new security protocols
unlocking the new electronic locks
requires a specially made battery pack
to be distributed to all employees
please keep your personal battery back
on and at all times when moving
throughout the Susilo t-this seems like
it takes a big battery pack hell is it
just for the doors what a burden you're
gonna get ripped if you work here all
right let's get gone and up hope oh it
floatees away oh it really does float ah
that's horrible I don't like it I don't
like it
see you around turd turd burg
alright let's get through here I guess
we can't go back well you know that's a
shame really wish I could but
unfortunately one-way street here we yep
that's what happens yeah that's what I
was suggesting ok
I remember in re - there were some sewer
monsters are we gonna be running into a
similar situation wait a minute oh what
a hand Grenada damn it I just I guess
I'm gonna have to use the hand Grenada
cuz if I don't actually use him then
they're just a big waste of a inventory
where am I going
woah alright did not know that this was
even here hello I did leo
why is this not open why isn't it why
why have you closed your doors to my
public alright fine then I'm assuming I
gotta open that from the other side
maybe there was something I could have
already opened but I didn't even notice
it because I'm in the idiot but I think
that's the security room that has the
the bag that I saw through the window so
if I just keep trucking forward did I
see something no if I keep trucking
forward I should find a way but I gotta
split up the path here so just really
depends on which way I'm feeling to say
how's office so that sounds pretty spike
what yeah I didn't actually one of
officer holy crap oh my god
frog [ __ ] okay definitely shoot it in
its mouth oh my god okay you know what
grief the ever there was a time for a
grenade it's now did you get oh there we
go oh my god okay I didn't actually
expect it to actually send a monster my
way I was just goofing and I was just
about to say oh boy I sure been done
quiet round these parts pardner sure
picked the wrong route hello oh wow oh
good explosive explosive you say is me
about to get a grenade launcher okay all
right cool good good good great great
great good great good great invoice from
gun shop kendo thank you for purchasing
the experts xxx grenade launcher we've
made special adjustments to this piece
to ensure compatibility with a variety
of ammunition types for optimal
performance be sure to choose the right
ammo for the right situation as we
discussed at the time of purchase this
is a refurbished model and the chamber
needs to be manually cycled between
shots it'll take an extra moment but
this is reflected in the price as agreed
explosive a flame round a plus B acid
round be twice mine rounds can't be
readily crafted not worth stocking up on
won't help if we need to keep the gammas
in line
okay I don't know what that means
I don't know what the gams are research
assistants logs gammas released from
tank for the first Oh movement sluggish
combat potential low experimented with
additional hormones and drugs wanted
just been more positive results with a
significant rise in combat potential
specimen is now able to move quickly in
swallow prey whole great umbrella has
officially shut down the gamma research
we managed to smuggle some specimens
with high especially high potential from
the lab before disposal dr. Logan
carly's is more committed than ever to
perfecting the gamma line two weeks ago
since relocating to the sewers increased
temperatures have led to a disc decrease
in water quality but specimens appear
fine despite my concerns game has
quickly learned the layout of the sewers
and within two days we're exploring the
entire underground of Raccoon City that
can't be good
all specimens are familiar with and
friendly towards us but I have procured
high-powered weaponry as a safeguard in
the event they become uncontrollable
September first we were lucky to secure
this place by bribing the sewage
department chief but it's beginning to
feel cramped due to the gamers continued
growth we should begin to consider other
possible arrangements the water
treatment worker found its way into the
lab but the game is promptly eliminated
this proves their viability for field
use I'll reach out to umbrellas European
branch tomorrow perhaps they will see
the light yeah I'm guessing day once
they got a help in a human then they
didn't want to they didn't wanna you
know I didn't want to deal with it I'm
gonna store that for now I'm just
because I have hand grenades and I'm
gonna use those and I think those will
take those things out with one shot just
like the grenade launcher would I bet
but yeah
whoa that's just so many bad decisions
you can see the bad decisions just
rolling out like I'm guessing this is a
gamma but hoo-hoo Nelly so many bad
choices all in a row like there's the
t-virus up above getting all experiment
on then even down below the sewers just
[ __ ] City whoever was in charge here
they're rich and dead okay you know what
this is how we do there we go
that get you oh it did not get you that
gotcha yeah you go there you go yeah
okay so it's uh one grenade and a couple
bullets and they go down like chumps
like chumps I say do I really want it I
really want to walk through that man
Raccoon City how are you still pooping
who who is still pooping you're all
zombies zombies don't poop Oh got
another one well good thing I got lots
of your nudes bop bip bap don't even try
it don't even try me loser nerd nerd
nerd you're a nerd that's what you get
nerd big nerds over here am i right
everybody I'm right right in the
comments are you right if I am right am
i right boob that's the problem
sorry if I sound bored here in those I
forgot those on there I'm sorry it's not
funny it's really not funny Hey look a
battery pack alright cool
see this thing is forget a huge I knew
it would be who's carrying this around
oh my god it's huge it's oh it's moving
Hughes I'm sorry that's not funny oh god
I've got so much crap in my inventory
good thing I didn't bring that other
thing yeah let's do this
who needs a grenade launcher not me no
way I'm not gonna drop anything for
nobody god dammit stop giving me crap I
don't want it oh my god I don't want it
here combine that with that combine that
with who oh I have to use this a love
letter my little darlings I don't like
how this is starting already it's
already been three months since we fled
here together I find myself thinking
back to the day you hatched your little
voices maybe tremble with pride your
adorable little bodies brimming with
incredible destructive power and of
course they have our Asus insatiable
appetite you are no less than the
pinnacle of the Hunter series and yet
they ordered me to destroy you
they said you are unfit for use as
weapons because of a few minor
vulnerabilities so what if you're
susceptible to heat so what if your
delicate mandibles are exposed when you
feed haven't they ever heard of
character flaws I love this letter so
much it is those very flaws that make
you so very very precious to me but
we'll show them yet down here we'll
continue to walk this evolutionary path
together will prove down below that you
my beloved hunter gammas are truly
superior written like a like a comedy
sketch right there I can't eat you damn
you
damn you green herb I don't need you cuz
I don't get hurt not emotionally not
physically not ever damn it there's
nothing I can do I got her Sudanese
herbs
I don't need her herbs I have barely
been hurt I know there's a [ __ ] been
there but eh you know who needs it
there's apparently another item in here
but I don't have the inventory space for
it so how do you expect me to deal with
it Oh flame rounds well I can't I can't
pick you those up so I have to come back
apparently I have to walk through the
ship more yeah I know you're there well
you were dead the whole time my mistake
goodbye citizen sewer workers knows it
happened again
they got Caine this time I saw did one
of those things just swallowed him whole
from head to toe I tried to warn them
when bill went missing two weeks back
the top said he'd brought skip down but
I said no way not with his baby coming
any day dad's never run away from their
babies but did they listen nerve this is
[ __ ]
[ __ ] cute Marie them toad face
[ __ ] every time I think I've
lost them another one pops out of
Turtles and one day I'll quit this damn
job but gotta pay the bills
I guess it's not like I can count a
little [ __ ] cops don't trust those
pencil pushers at HQ neither next time
one of those freaks shows its face I'm
gonna hit it god this explains so much
everyone's an idiot
everyone's so dumb you saw your friend
gets swallowed from head tutor
you're gonna punch it yeah I run your
big ugly man no boom thank you swallow
me Wanda I'm gonna swallow you what'd
that work out for you well you didn't
get swallowed old so I'm guessing it
worked out great
I'm guessing just just the goddamn best
you know what I mean you know what I
mean man okay so there's a lot I tunes
in this hallway that I need to get god I
love you know Raccoon City they were
doomed from the get-go but you gotta
love them like God let's see if I can do
this without Grenada Wow
okay reload and make grinnell ii was a
big help
yeah okay man you take a lot of shooties
come on well I don't need grenades
you gonna die yet man your big ugly
mouth is man how powerful of that guy's
punches that he thought that he was
gonna go mano a frog Oh with a hunter
gamma I have so much [ __ ] okay I have
gunpowder good thing to know that
shotgun does do a bit of doobage to
those boots but a grenade is much more
effective somehow to the pinnacle of the
hunter species my left nut stupid idiots
all right so I'm gonna switch out I'm
gonna play hopscotch with some of this
crap in here explode I'm not gonna mix
anything until I know that I actually
need to use some of that crap you know
actually I'll be right back I'm just
gonna go get the crap and I'm gonna come
back I'm a store at all that's what I
have to do unless something horrible
jumps on me in the sewer I will see you
in a spell bad news gang nothing
horrible jumped on me while I
as a masseur turns out it was a whole
hullabaloo hello but nothing why do I
have a knife what good does this knife
do me literally ever and sentimental I
guess I'm just a sucker you know how it
is you all know how it is okay I didn't
even delete my bolt cutters you know cuz
I didn't think I wanted to all right but
anyway we got all the items there we've
got a battery so we can open a door
which is good because I'm assuming
that's gonna lead us back either towards
the hip pouch or towards an objective of
some kind hey stop it no no no no no no
no come on reload come on yah yah yah
yah yah won't
wonkish you've got a big dumb mouth Oh
dead already
beautiful pathetic the pinnacle of my
ass more like it eat a dong that I don't
have time to open that door those guys
aren't so bad at all actually they're
not nearly as bad as the ones that would
throw likes cuddling's cuttlefish at you
whatever those things were anyway use
swamp love the new key boss really great
design boss well done boss thanks boss
where am i all right
what hey well listen
Wow you were a little too close on
reload long listen you are barely a
threat
Oh long yeah that's what I thought
you're not even nothing you're nothing I
mean I am wasting literally all of my
show kun mo man all that just to do that
and then just get this thing back in
real secure boss definitely didn't just
go through the yellow gate buy it no no
no good good purchase decision boss
great job boss really stellar stuff boss
thank you this I love you boss
love you hello yes thank you I love it
thank you candy do mind if I do
anything in here that I need anything
else in here than I need to
ooh there's something else in here what
else is in here than it it's worse
explosives perfect for security
why does it why does a sir need a
security room kind of hellhole of an
assignment would be permanently in the
sewer security room that would suck so
intensely oh no someone could fall all
right come back now I love sewers live
to deal up down today Lobby huh love
Buddha birdie all right just gotta be
gonna be something else to this right
can't just be this hat and bam boom I'm
done seems like it really wants to make
it as if top soup I'm done hmm hmm
should I try to go back to the an ABS
I'm fine I don't need it I'm just
wondering if I should have gotten the
grenade launcher but I'm willing to bet
that I'm
can you hear me now yeah I'm alive I
lost him I'm covered in [ __ ] too but
that's a side note what I swear I heard
a second set of footprints I swear that
was weird was I alone on that or anyone
else notice that I was very weird very
weird okay that's a second set of
footprints all right don't crush my
skull don't do it please don't
was this a boss fight I really should
have gotten I really should have gotten
the oh I should have oh I should have
gotten the oh yeah just fall away I
gotta go oh I didn't check that area for
items types well did I lose anything
over there I bet I did not well it don't
matter
god damn it here can use weapons yeah
well you know it's only fair
oh here we go perfect perfect perfect
perfect we got it's placebo out of beale
herb Adil oh let's see it's really
anything that we actually wanted do I
don't really need the grenade launcher
I guess why'd it is a cool item so I
guess I should use it got all this crap
in here look at how much crap I got I
got so much chrome lots of explosives
should I should I should I not know
you know what let's I don't need it
right now
I really don't I'm just gonna go with
hand granades
and I'm gonna see what happens with that
cuz I think I'm doing good I like having
my inventory nice and open and he's a
chump so honestly I'm gonna kick his
dick in and he's going to thank me for
it
cuz that's just how this deal works all
right buddy boo let's get a taste to you
am i right all right
I'm right I am right okay let's just go
up and see what the deal is sure does
sound ominous
all right buds uh don't mind me how
about excuse me Oh miss me stupid idiot
yep that's me stirs hey can you you not
do that no wonder everything is on fire
in the city with your stupid
flamethrower oh I see oh yeah perfect
bridge very haphazard nothing
there's no items nowhere oh wow yeah
real mature buddy furs maybe I should
have gotten the grenade hey bud don't
mind me No
got that maybe I should have gotten the
grenade launcher because it does seem
like this is gonna be a boss fight hey
bud how you doing power nemesis heavy
SUSE SUSE the sister nanny mom ooh no
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh Oh
how you doing naming new nematode sus
man sus lady I'm no judge I would never
assume did I miss anything that's not
gonna be any IDs here Aaron I mean items
I opened my inventory for absolutely
nothing
oh good thing no one lives in this
building
mostly cuz it's under construction don't
know how I got this high up
how did I get this I was in the sewers
wait I was in the sewers how do they get
this high up uh hell happened oh now
this this is boss fight time okay this
is where I need to pull out the grenade
launcher I see it you think I'm stupid
no stop okay uh flame rounds a plus B I
think those are gotta be better they're
advertising them so a plus B let's make
some flame rounds baby there we go
that's what I call good stuff and I'll
put the grenades in a way who knows
maybe I'll need them okay so they hold
the max of six I'm not even gonna bother
with the bigger rounds let's do this one
shot one kill
I am an expert just taking a spray just
in case for some reason or not I am NOT
an expert which is Oh down you go wait
wait wait notice of demolition delay we
have decided to delay the bond of the
office building demolition response
ongoing public unrest the safety reasons
all electrical equipment including
generators have been moved to the roof
first
whoa all right entreated the promises
ribbit didn't know the current unrest
has subsided long blazer to stay at home
and await further instructions Oh Moo my
you telling me the shooty shooty
electrical generators are all up on the
roof hmm oh wait no that's not what I
was looking for
nice jump Suzie sister na ma so namaste
let me see what this does do you two can
play at the flame game defeat the
creature all right well no need to be
rude yeah makes sense I like the sound
of that
I got your weak spot baby whoo
cherry miss man loser nerd
Oh what the hell that's not how fire
works it is how fireworks works so I
guess you got that
oh wow
I'm in danger that hurt a lot turns out
you don't don't walk straight through
the [ __ ] bubble I'll take that you son
of a [ __ ] okay never mind you'll take
that you son of a [ __ ] all right
oh well sweet dodge that was really good
stuff scary one-shot wonder pop flap
this is how we do in the streets so we
do on stars streets ah you couldn't roll
yeesh
Easter's you stirs my keisters how is
that still spitting flame
how are you still spitting flaming
spores yeah that's what you get
oh I'm running nemesis is more like
Nemec douche nematode more like NEMA
load ow
well this was risky business there goes
my ribs no not my ribs he was aiming
right for my ribs my one weakness
yeah when she's done she's gonna be down
to just one rib left got her poor ribs
alright
nemesis down definitely I think for
suresies Susie we're never gonna see
Seuss again the sister is dunzo do you
read me you'll never believe it
[Music]
don't start I did what I had to did I
gain them did I gain the begrudging
admiration of your commanding officer or
whoever the hell the white-haired guy
was the white-haired white guy you
remember him
lovely lovely lovely person but did I
get his admiration that's literally the
only reason I did that he he was a
meanie meanie bow beanie to me and I I
just needed to prove he wove II him
wrong II wanna what I mean there's
something over there probably up on the
ladder I doubt I'm missing it over here
so it's probably
oh no it's right there oh boy okay la la
la la la la la up the ladder I go I've
always wanted to run a little woowoo
here whoo oh I'm a fire lady oh goodness
la da de Lulu well this is convenient
can I sneak you're moving in slow motion
my dude interesting well I don't want to
blast that right away what a waste
think about funk hey douche douche what
wait a minute oh no no way hey come on
hey you join the party
join the fun join the fun go on the run
join the fun come on join the fun
everybody join the fun join the fun join
the fun
I missed one I don't even need to shoot
you
oh hey it's the thing it's the place
they said this is the police department
this place way under way on all right
fine
be that way nerds douches douche holes
ah there it is Oh fun it was down here
Oh big boy gunpowder I will need that
was it the only thing here yes it's were
and expected me to come down and call
for Leon but it didn't expect me who to
look to the right our way to know it
expected me to do that and that's the
only thing I didn't do my sentence does
make sense
you all know this you all know this am I
going to the gun shop and I'm gonna take
the good gun before Leon can get here me
mine I want icy urban there me my movie
aha
well time to nab all the good stuff mmm
semi-auto barrel that sounds really fun
oh but I don't want it Oh what does the
semi on a barrel do design for
semi-automatic fire less for more rapid
firing while reducing spread for greater
power that sounds good fine I'll do it
and two more bullets apparently well
more bullets as well all right you have
my attention
suck it Leon your shotguns gonna suck
forever
Leon more like do Sean
he's dead he's literally dead he's he'll
never recover from that one he's gone
forever
oh hey whoa hey you're all right yeah
all right so stretch
sorry I get a little jumpy there didn't
know quite what to expect no [ __ ]
look we're using the subway to get
people out of town you win
subway Wow that's good thinking when we
get out there's gonna be a lot to do we
can use a man of your skill set
what's wrong nothing just uh just bad
timing is all no look don't worry about
me I'm gonna make other arrangements
okay you better give us gunsmith around
oh no don't do anything stupid
oh that's that's your job right take
care Jill oh no no no god oh god kendo
kendo can go oh that's I mean I've
already know I already know that story
and I'm still sad about it sad sad all
right I'm gonna put away all this I'm
gonna put away the grenade launcher just
because I'm expecting there to be more
of a final mmm that's not what I wanted
to do take it out combined that there
I'm expecting there to be like a final
battle kind of thing going on and I'm
assuming that it's going to be a big
deal nope god damn at and I will save it
for that time when it comes and now for
now I think pistol and shotgun is the
good combo I think what I'm going to do
is I'm going to try to emphasize the
pistol hopefully I can get another
attachment for this pistol
that'll make it even better but for now
Lucas and Yatta Yatta will be fine nope
they use care chunk could jump perfect
perfect perfect is that all I needed to
keep for apparently and because I'm
insane I'm not well actually wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
do not get up do not get up good good
because I'm actually insane oh I hate it
I hate it you were not supposed to get
up you were not supposed to get up you
were not supposed to get up I'm gonna
put the key away and this or but herb
alright I'm coming for you you're gonna
get a face full of blam in two shakes of
a lamb's tail where did that expression
come from I have no idea hey bud are you
doing bud I hate everything about you
what are you doing oh you think you can
just open the door if you just open the
door ah you can open the door I didn't
know that
you thought you could open a door you
fool where are you going well wrong way
good for you and good for you that's one
way to take care of someone hey bud can
I shoot you right in your big dumb eye
hole oh I hate it here oh you got lot
longer range than I thought you did oh
my god I hate you no do not do not oh hi
no no no no no nothing about anything
that just happened I don't know what the
hell that was all about you all suck I
missed something in there god damn it I
have to go back god damn it god damn
it's not worth it definitely not worth
it oh uh you know what shotgun time
nice job putting your head right in the
way really appreciate that big breach my
god I'm a loser I'm a dumb-dumb I'm big
dumb big dumb big dumb ours over here
what did I miss why did I miss it how
did I miss it got one gun back I did all
that for one you know what I'm gonna
keep it I'm gonna keep this on me mommy
just in case I get a high grade because
screw the pistol it's wimpiest balls
it's super stupi and super wimpy and I
need to get better at dodging don't
Wimpy pistol time it's wimpy pistol
hours there you go that's what I thought
you got taken out by a wimpy ice pistol
little baby pistol you [ __ ]
all right where am I I've never been
here before yeah hello mind if I
hey buddy please don't no don't do it
show me your show me your butthole okay
fine we're doing it this way
Wow I can't hit me through walls miss me
there you go get down you weirdo okay
this is good stuff I hear something
upstairs upstairs who's out there
KaBlam over that's what I thought
racoon Times reader calm dear editor I'm
writing you because I'm troubled deeply
troubled anyone who's been a parent
knows that Crystal promenade is the
place to take your kids for a trip
downtown on Saturdays and there's no
store more popular or harder on a
parent's wallet than toy uncle however
I've noticed that on windy days the big
statue above the entrance wobbles like
it's only using holding up its a couple
screws if the statue is that doubles
loose on a busy day children will be
badly hurt I've complained to the
manager three times now but he isn't
willing to rectify the situation are we
supposed to wait for a terrible accident
to happen before taking action know if
heads are gonna roll then let it be the
managers take down that deathtrap
Timothy wails good good call Timothy
you're right Timothy you right there's
one thing you write about big heads
thank you
not that I needed it but thank you for
that sir chest downstairs or am I crazy
no there was a chest before but I'm not
going back for it just yet I don't need
to do that there was nothing else in
here I'm hurt but I'll live Let's Get
gone
BAM well that was less explosive see
Jill you're really inconsistent on your
explosive dramatic exits and entrances
and you really need to work at something
that Leon was really good at whoa like
that CEO
[Applause]
do not don't dude I walked into that one
well miss me miss me loser okay
epic dodge epic dodge epic dodge epic
dodge epic god haha why didn't that guy
not get blown dodged you like a pro Oh
miss me you're gonna get Wow you shot
two too quickly you're gonna get holy
try me try me try me Oh nope try me
why didn't you just get down here so I
can shoot you okay I guess it just
wasn't gonna happen period only there
was a giant head to drop on somebody
are you a failure
no no Jill you need to dodge a little
quicker there please okay
well that's not good
good thinking these are slow grenades
thanks for the assist buddy needed help
getting over that my ribs
ouches
if only I read an article about a giant
head mm I see a giant head ouchies ah
all better
let's take care of those rocket launcher
wounds oh that's still little Wibbly do
I need more or am I just
oh my ribs have finally caught up to me
I see finally finally
what am i a big [ __ ] baby you know it
seems like it big [ __ ] baby ours over
here okay hello
Yello and I'm back here I don't know if
there's anything new to get okay well I
was going to the station anyway so I
don't know why you needed to specify
that I needed to go to the station
because it was already gonna happen it
was like a certainty that I was gonna do
that so hmm hey bud
big head no no that was my plan
oh my god Oh Becca oh my god what the
hell
well the physics were a little strange
on that but oh you're there goddamnit I
did that one second too early please no
not like this anything but this
Oh God alright which way am I go hey bud
Wow that would have heard if you would
have hit me but you didn't cuz you're a
nerd nerd yikes
yippee Wow hey okay where am I going
what what am i where am I mmm in the toy
store oh this way no not in the toy
store literally this way the way that I
the only way I could have gone hey
thanks thank you
you can stay out a little long Oh Big E
Oh Big E Oh No all right thanks Big E oh
whoa take some of that
go go there we go there's some help
nice nice I don't think that's out fuel
trucks work I don't think they just wait
walking bombs the slightest slightest
impact explodes a minute
biggie you're my hero I love how many
hip pouches you have about your
inventory is huge you saved my ass first
you're a hell of a lot braver than me
well what matters is that you know yeah
you'll be safe
what about you from the sound of it I
won't be catching the train why not
no there be new orders
if it means I can help save the city
that's fine by me
okay cool your lips weren't quite
matching what you were saying and if but
it didn't remove the emotional impact of
the importance of the decision you're
about to make to stay behind save
everybody biggie
sorry I'm distracted by the posters
behind you but biggie you're a hero
always will be hey where's that newfound
respect I ordered God's work your
reputation is well-deserved get inside
this Subway's about to leave Carlos
Tyrell you have your orders you need to
go back out into the city and find that
Daniel part this isn't the last van out
of town right
do not worry once the civilians are safe
that train will be back it's all right
you go on ahead I'm not gonna die on you
leave you in a cold cruel Carlos this
world okay yeah you'll need to find this
scientist
it's vaccine the research could save us
all
you see you're loaning your little life
that mythos is your Wester wanna be
let's go
I want to go there you don't really
think Vincent Porsche like you will read
about demons there is something else
funny a brainless zombies can ambush a
platoon like that funny the gate was
locked don't you think yes that's the
civilians oh this way
Nicholi what are you doing it's not
after how did I even know your name well
then that guy's cool Nikolai
or as I call him numbnuts numbnuts ain't
so cool now it's been a while
Subway's got to be clear this city by
now along with your hot date so cool
with her hair and her boobs everything
about her just so great gun Wow am I
about to play as Carlos now I am aren't
I
how BIG's my inventory all my
inventories not nearly as big as I
thought it was gonna be Wow but that gun
just got a little nub longer I see you
this wowee-wow-wow
mama well gee mom oh wait this looks
like a better knife to watch wah wah
whee-wah alright let's go buddy
lead the way it was about mo buddy
Dabangg but you didn't put the
bo-buddies I don't know what the hell
I'm saying mealy way oh no that's how he
got got oh that's how he got got oh it
all connects I can't believe it all
connects [ __ ]
knock on the door say hi alright this is
God dang
milk your bread and yellow jacket loser
no no you don't he's tough he's got
thick nog hey listen you're not pretty
thick no his his nog is just so thick
hey I got his ID card these stars that
could see I wasn't gonna little nerd
weed with kind of shrine by such nerds
we back in hey it was a cop go don't
know don't care we got a job to do our
Intel's still worth a damn then bards in
the Stars office let's find him and take
him into custody custody I thought this
was a rescue
Carlos take a look at this what oh ok to
the stars office remember Bart had
access to umbrellas darkest secrets he
knows we'll try to keep him under our
thumbs so this search and rescue mission
is really more like fine to detain hmm
right
good to know I'll open the shutter so
you can get through you stay here and
find out what's been going on here at
the station call you if I find anything
hmm Thanks be careful oh well thank you
thank you friend so nice so lovely and
nice so nice to be so nice all right
well we're officially done with the Jill
kid a dear nerd stop for Big E to step
onto this that's name it's not right I
can't be right what are they doing
stupid they think I'm dumb
they think I'm dumb don't they they
think I'm really really really dumb
anybody grown ever wonder pull this
lever here our first date I refuse all
right so that'll do for this episode
here we're back in the police station
now where where I hope that bliss
officer didn't need this herb right here
well a weird [ __ ] door
all right well anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching hope
you're enjoying it I know I am take care
yourselves look out for more coming at
you a hot and heavy on a regular basis I
love it I really do this game is it's
something about it like the gameplays is
very fun I can't wait to play through it
again on a harder difficulty so thank
you as always I will see you in the next
week
bye-bye
[Music]